wait who's that wait look Brad mister
the guy you're better gonna wear it what
go buy something hello to her hello
she's gonna have the number one song in
the nation call your local radio
stations in request actually though I
know he's so sweet he's so supportive
he's awesome that performance
how did it feel it was so fun I mean
I've never really actually done a solo
performance with pyro before so I'm just
holding my phone case I want my dog on I
wouldn't get burned or anything did you
know I don't think you'd feel the heat
and I'm like I have a lot of weave and
hair product and it was so fun I mean
the song is so like empowered and strong
from a woman's standpoint so I feel like
I wanted to like have a sucker punch
doesn't it from it so you have to
rehearse when you know there's gonna be
like pyro going on yeah yeah yeah
definitely you have to know where it's
gonna happen don't go that far back on
the stage all that was there ever a
moment tonight where you went like oops
I went too far
a couple inches I think you know in
rehearsals you everything all of that
but when there's a full arena full of
people and then you look over there's
all the artists you just want to impress
people you want to do your best so
they're like I get her thing I get what
what it is that she does so I was kind
of just like just go nail it so people
understand what you do yeah did you feel
the empowerment for girls for women
after the performance there were a lot
of there there was a lot of like woman
epicness tonight in general oh yeah
absolutely I think we kind of it's
getting to the point where it's like we
don't have to say it we just like show
up we do our thing and it's like all
right we get it
you're awesome you know like with Maren
and Cheryl and Brandi and like even
Trisha showing up like I'm like oh my
god
[Music]